The world is an increasingly urban place. About 80% of Americans live in and around cities, according to the U.S. Census Bureau. And with urban living comes traffic, noise, pollution, and other hassles of daily life that can exact a toll on our mental health. But cities don't have to wear us down. Psychologists who study urban design and mental health say that by incorporating elements like access to nature, opportunities for exercise, and space, that encourage community, it's possible to design urban areas that support our mental health and
The world is an increasingly urban place. About 80% of Americans live in and around cities, according to the U.S. Census Bureau. And with urban living comes traffic, noise, pollution, and other hassles of daily life that can exact a toll on our mental health. But cities don't have to wear us down. Psychologists who study urban design and mental health say that by incorporating elements like access to nature, opportunities for exercise, and space, that encourage community, it's possible to design urban areas that support our mental health and|||世界正日益城市化。根据美国人口普查局的数据，大约80%的美国人生活在城市及周边地区。伴随着城市生活而来的，是交通、噪音、污染以及日常生活的其他烦恼，这些都会对我们的心理健康造成损害。但城市并不一定会把我们压垮。研究城市设计和心理健康的心理学家表示，通过融入亲近自然、提供锻炼机会以及鼓励社区发展的空间等元素，完全有可能设计出支持我们心理健康和
well-being. So how does our physical environment affect our mental health? What aspects of city design matter most? Are there cities doing an especially good job of designing for mental health? And if so, what can other cities learn from them? And what about issues of equity and access? How can cities ensure that all residents have access to the kinds of spaces that promote mental health? What can you do in your own community to make a difference. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Jenny Rowe, Director of the Center for Design and Health in the School of Architecture at the University of Virginia. She's an environmental
well-being. So how does our physical environment affect our mental health? What aspects of city design matter most? Are there cities doing an especially good job of designing for mental health? And if so, what can other cities learn from them? And what about issues of equity and access? How can cities ensure that all residents have access to the kinds of spaces that promote mental health? What can you do in your own community to make a difference. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Jenny Rowe, Director of the Center for Design and Health in the School of Architecture at the University of Virginia. She's an environmental|||福祉的城市空间。那么，我们的物理环境是如何影响我们的心理健康的呢？城市设计的哪些方面最重要？有没有哪些城市在心理健康导向的设计方面做得特别好？如果是的话，其他城市可以向它们学习什么？公平和获取权的问题又该如何解决？城市如何确保所有居民都能获得促进心理健康的各种空间？你能在自己的社区做些什么来带来改变。欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客节目《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），本节目探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是吉姆·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是弗吉尼亚大学建筑学院设计与健康中心主任珍妮·罗（Jenny Rowe）博士。她是一位环境
psychologist who studies the intersection of health and well-being with architecture and urban design. Her research interests include creating environments that support mental health, designing cities for healthy aging, and healthy child and adolescent development, and studying how nature affects health and well-being. She's written numerous peer-reviewed studies and two books, the most recent of which is restorative cities, urban design for mental health and well-being. Dr. Roe, thank you for joining me today. Well, thank you for inviting me. Pleasures to be here. So as I said, your book is called restorative cities, so let's start by defining. that term, what constitutes a restorative city?
psychologist who studies the intersection of health and well-being with architecture and urban design. Her research interests include creating environments that support mental health, designing cities for healthy aging, and healthy child and adolescent development, and studying how nature affects health and well-being. She's written numerous peer-reviewed studies and two books, the most recent of which is restorative cities, urban design for mental health and well-being. Dr. Roe, thank you for joining me today. Well, thank you for inviting me. Pleasures to be here. So as I said, your book is called restorative cities, so let's start by defining. that term, what constitutes a restorative city?|||心理学家，研究健康和福祉与建筑及城市设计的交汇点。她的研究兴趣包括创造支持心理健康的生存环境、为健康老龄化以及儿童和青少年的健康发展设计城市，以及研究自然如何影响健康和福祉。她撰写了大量同行评审的研究报告和两本书，其中最新的一本是《恢复性城市：心理健康与福祉的城市设计》。罗博士，谢谢你今天能来参加我们的节目。不客气，谢谢你的邀请，很高兴能来到这里。正如我所说，你的书名叫《恢复性城市》，让我们从定义这个词开始吧，究竟什么构成了“恢复性城市”？
Well, restorative cities is a term coined from a rubric of research in psychology that goes under the name of restorative environment research. A restorative environment is any environment inside or outdoors that supports your mental health. So that's where the term restorative cities originated from. What is the opposite then? What is an environment that isn't restorative? Well, a pathogenic environment, one that has toxins, one that has poor air quality, one that has a high level of noise pollution, and a gray area, an area that has no nature. It has nothing to engage our interest or our attention. Homogenous neighborhoods, neighborhoods that all look the same. That sounds quite bleak.
Well, restorative cities is a term coined from a rubric of research in psychology that goes under the name of restorative environment research. A restorative environment is any environment inside or outdoors that supports your mental health. So that's where the term restorative cities originated from. What is the opposite then? What is an environment that isn't restorative? Well, a pathogenic environment, one that has toxins, one that has poor air quality, one that has a high level of noise pollution, and a gray area, an area that has no nature. It has nothing to engage our interest or our attention. Homogenous neighborhoods, neighborhoods that all look the same. That sounds quite bleak.|||嗯，“恢复性城市”这个词源于心理学的一个研究范畴，该范畴被称为“恢复性环境研究”。恢复性环境是指任何能够支持你心理健康的室内或户外环境。这就是“恢复性城市”一词的由来。那么与之相反的是什么呢？什么样的环境才是不具备恢复性的？嗯，致病环境，即含有毒素的环境、空气质量差的环境、噪音污染严重的环境，还有灰色地带，也就是没有自然界介入的区域。那里没有什么能激起我们的兴趣或注意力。同质化的街区，也就是看起来千篇一律的街区。听起来确实相当惨淡。
You can probably picture it, though. I can. The first chapter of your book is called The Green City and it's all about access to nature. How does contact with nature affect our mental health and what does nature look like in a city, in an urban area? Nature is possibly the most restorative attributes in our environment, either indoors or out. And what's so extraordinary about nature is it provides four psychological attributes that we know support our mental health. The first is a sense of fascination. That would be a sense of curiosity and wonder and awe even. The second is a sense of an extent.
You can probably picture it, though. I can. The first chapter of your book is called The Green City and it's all about access to nature. How does contact with nature affect our mental health and what does nature look like in a city, in an urban area? Nature is possibly the most restorative attributes in our environment, either indoors or out. And what's so extraordinary about nature is it provides four psychological attributes that we know support our mental health. The first is a sense of fascination. That would be a sense of curiosity and wonder and awe even. The second is a sense of an extent.|||不过你大概能在脑海中勾勒出那个画面。我能。你书的第一章叫《绿色城市》，内容完全关于亲近自然。接触自然如何影响我们的心理健康？在城市或城区中，自然又是什么样子的？无论在室内还是室外，自然可能都是我们环境中最重要的恢复性属性。自然最非凡的地方在于，它提供了四个我们所知的支持心理健康的心理学属性。首先是着迷感（fascination）。这是一种好奇心、惊叹感，甚至是敬畏感。其次是延展感（extent）。
An extent might be defined as looking at a view from perhaps your window, looking at the mountaintops. I see mountains where I work. I work in Virginia. I see the Blue Ridge Mountains. I don't know what you see from your office, but looking up and out of your environment fosters this idea of extent and connecting to a whole other world
An extent might be defined as looking at a view from perhaps your window, looking at the mountaintops. I see mountains where I work. I work in Virginia. I see the Blue Ridge Mountains. I don't know what you see from your office, but looking up and out of your environment fosters this idea of extent and connecting to a whole other world|||延展感可以被定义为透过你的窗户眺望风景，比如远眺山巅。我在工作的地方能看到山。我在弗吉尼亚工作，我能看到蓝岭山脉（Blue Ridge Mountains）。我不知道从你的办公室望出去能看到什么，但抬头向外眺望你的环境，能够培养这种延展感的理念，并让你与另一个完全不同的世界建立联系
beyond the world you're in right now. A sense of compatibility, nature will provide us with opportunities for refuge, perhaps, or for opportunities to interact with family and friends. Parks provide opportunities for play, the picnics. So it provides a lot of opportunities in terms of our needs and our goals in life, our social goals, particularly. And then the final and possibly the most important attribute nature
beyond the world you're in right now. A sense of compatibility, nature will provide us with opportunities for refuge, perhaps, or for opportunities to interact with family and friends. Parks provide opportunities for play, the picnics. So it provides a lot of opportunities in terms of our needs and our goals in life, our social goals, particularly. And then the final and possibly the most important attribute nature|||超越你此刻身处的世界。还有契合感（compatibility），自然会为我们提供庇护的机会，或者与家人朋友互动的机会。公园为游戏和野餐提供了场所。因此，在满足我们的需求、生活目标（特别是社会目标）方面，它提供了大量的机会。最后，也是可能最重要的属性，自然
can provide is a sense of being away, a sense of escape from our everyday stresses. And what's really important, and I'd like to stress to your listeners, is that contact with nature doesn't need to be in a wilderness. Contact with nature in a city can be on a very small scale. It can be a pocket park. It can be a balcony with plants. It can be a view to nature from your window. Direct contact actually getting out and about in a park and moving physically provides a whole host of mental health benefits. But let's say you're a retired person or you're sick. You can't move around so easily, having a view of nature is super important. And you'd be amazed at the number of senior residences I go into where the window is above the eye level of the person actually
can provide is a sense of being away, a sense of escape from our everyday stresses. And what's really important, and I'd like to stress to your listeners, is that contact with nature doesn't need to be in a wilderness. Contact with nature in a city can be on a very small scale. It can be a pocket park. It can be a balcony with plants. It can be a view to nature from your window. Direct contact actually getting out and about in a park and moving physically provides a whole host of mental health benefits. But let's say you're a retired person or you're sick. You can't move around so easily, having a view of nature is super important. And you'd be amazed at the number of senior residences I go into where the window is above the eye level of the person actually|||能够提供的是抽离感（being away），一种逃离日常生活压力的感觉。非常重要的一点，也是我想向听众强调的是，接触自然并不一定要去荒野。在城市中接触自然可以是非常小规模的。它可以是一个袖珍公园。可以是一个摆满植物的阳台。可以是从窗户望出去的自然景色。直接接触——实际上就是走到公园里去活动身体——能带来全方位的心理健康益处。但假设你是一个退休人员或者你生病了，无法自如活动，那么拥有自然景观的视野就超级重要了。你会惊讶地发现，在我去过的许多老年人住宅中，窗户的高度竟然高于实际住在
living in that room. So there's fundamentals like that that are really important. Your book characterizes many aspects of cities. You talk about green, blue, sensory, neighborly, just to name a few. What are these various types of cities? Why do you classify them as you do? Thematically, we thought Leila and I, who's a psychiatrist who I worked on the book with, we believed it was important to try and have these seven pillars. Not all pillars are possible, but most people can breathe a little bit of nature into an environment, even in a very, very small way, be it, as I said, you know, having balconies and having plants on those balconies.
living in that room. So there's fundamentals like that that are really important. Your book characterizes many aspects of cities. You talk about green, blue, sensory, neighborly, just to name a few. What are these various types of cities? Why do you classify them as you do? Thematically, we thought Leila and I, who's a psychiatrist who I collaborated on the book with, we believed it was important to try and have these seven pillars. Not all pillars are possible, but most people can breathe a little bit of nature into an environment, even in a very, very small way, be it, as I said, you know, having balconies and having plants on those balconies.|||那个房间里的人的视线水平。所以诸如此类的基础设计真的非常重要。你的书对城市的许多方面进行了特征描述。你谈到了绿色、蓝色、感官、邻里等等。这些不同类型的城市是什么？你为什么要这样进行分类？在主题上，我和莱拉（Leila）——她是和我合作这本书的精神病学家——认为，尝试建立这七个支柱是很重要的。并非所有的支柱都能够实现，但大多数人都可以向环境中注入一点点自然，哪怕是以非常非常小的方式，比如正如我所说，拥有阳台并在阳台上种满植物。
Some are more difficult to create. You know, neighbourly cities require a community to really have access to some community space in which to interact. During COVID, we saw how important the outdoors became to our social well-being, our physical well-being, our mental health. Our streets, for example, provided the context in which we interacted with our neighbours. So we have seven pillars. there are a different scale and some are more easy to implement than others and they all interact with each other. So let's just give an example of that. So access to nature provides also opportunities for social interaction and communication. And so it contributes to the neighbourly city.
Some are more difficult to create. You know, neighbourly cities require a community to really have access to some community space in which to interact. During COVID, we saw how important the outdoors became to our social well-being, our physical well-being, our mental health. Our streets, for example, provided the context in which we interacted with our neighbours. So we have seven pillars. there are a different scale and some are more easy to implement than others and they all interact with each other. So let's just give an example of that. So access to nature provides also opportunities for social interaction and communication. And so it contributes to the neighbourly city.|||有些则更难打造。你知道，邻里城市要求社区真正拥有一些可以进行互动的社区空间。在疫情期间，我们看到了户外对我们的社会福祉、身体健康和心理健康是多么重要。例如，我们的街道为我们与邻居互动提供了场景。所以我们有七个支柱，它们的规模不同，有些比其他的更容易实施，而且它们相互作用。让我们举个例子。亲近自然同时也提供了社交和沟通的机会。因此，它有助于打造邻里城市。
Access to nature is also I advocate for a human right and need. And that again during COVID, what we saw was inequalities, environmental and health inequalities in access to green space in the city. Are there any cities that have all of the pillars or most of them? Can you give us some examples of some cities that are really restorative? I think it would be hard for any city to meet all of those pillars through the entire population of a city. We're talking about millions of people that inhabit cities. I think an example I would quote, which is very newsworthy at the moment, is Paris. So the mayor of Paris, around about COVID time, 2021, she was re-elected on an urban design mandate. And what she said she was going to give Paris was a restorative environment.
Access to nature is also I advocate for a human right and need. And that again during COVID, what we saw was inequalities, environmental and health inequalities in access to green space in the city. Are there any cities that have all of the pillars or most of them? Can you give us some examples of some cities that are really restorative? I think it would be hard for any city to meet all of those pillars through the entire population of a city. We're talking about millions of people that inhabit cities. I think an example I would quote, which is very newsworthy at the moment, is Paris. So the mayor of Paris, around about COVID time, 2021, she was re-elected on an urban design mandate. And what she said she was going to give Paris was a restorative environment.|||亲近自然也是我所倡导的一项人权和需求。同样在疫情期间，我们看到的是城市绿地获取方面的不平等，即环境和健康的不平等。有没有哪座城市拥有所有的支柱或大部分支柱？你能给我们举几个真正具有恢复性的城市例子吗?我认为任何城市都很难让全市所有人口都满足所有这些支柱。我们谈论的是居住在城市中的数百万人口。我想引用的一个例子是目前极具新闻价值的城市——巴黎。巴黎市长在疫情期间的大约2021年，凭借城市设计的施政纲领再次当选。她当时表示，她要给巴黎带来的是一个恢复性的环境。
She didn't use those words, but that's what I inferred from what she said. And she set about with her urban design manifesto that was about retaining all those pop-up streets and pop-up cycle lanes. And she is removing transport from within the centre of Paris. And just today there's been a vote in Paris, I think, to increase the amount that SUVs are charged for parking, it's going to be three times a rate of any other car because the people in Paris don't want them their city center. So there's a lot of things happening in Paris. The other thing I'd say about Paris is they really sees the idea that children need safe and high-quality environments to walk to school too. They're creating play streets in the vicinity of schools. They're making access
She didn't use those words, but that's what I inferred from what she said. And she set about with her urban design manifesto that was about retaining all those pop-up streets and pop-up cycle lanes. And she is removing transport from within the centre of Paris. And just today there's been a vote in Paris, I think, to increase the amount that SUVs are charged for parking, it's going to be three times a rate of any other car because the people in Paris don't want them their city center. So there's a lot of things happening in Paris. The other thing I'd say about Paris is they really sees the idea that children need safe and high-quality environments to walk to school too. They're creating play streets in the vicinity of schools. They're making access|||她虽然没有使用这些字眼，但这是我从她的话中推断出来的。她着手实施她的城市设计宣言，其核心是保留所有那些临时街道和临时自行车道。她正在将交通工具移出巴黎市中心。就在今天，巴黎好像进行了一项投票，决定提高SUV的停车收费标准，这将是其他任何汽车费率的三倍，因为巴黎人民不希望它们出现在市中心。所以巴黎正在发生很多事情。关于巴黎，我想说的另一件事是，他们真正把握住了这样一个理念：儿童也需要安全和高质量的环境步行上学。他们正在学校附近创建游戏街道。他们正在让出行变得
to school much more walkable and safer. It would seem to me that various cities could have these elements in different parts of them. As you mentioned, cities can be quite large. So I for many years in New York City, as an example. There's Central Park, but there are also parks in Brooklyn. There are parks in the Bronx. There are other places. And of course, you're on an island, so you're near the water. You can see the water. It's New York restorative in that sense, but it's very loud. So how do these things work together? Well, I'm going to give you an example in New York. It's called Pately Park, and it's just off a main roadway, probably four or five lanes of traffic. It's right in the heart of the city and it's flooded with water.
to school much more walkable and safer. It would seem to me that various cities could have these elements in different parts of them. As you mentioned, cities can be quite large. So I for many years in New York City, as an example. There's Central Park, but there are also parks in Brooklyn. There are parks in the Bronx. There are other places. And of course, you're on an island, so you're near the water. You can see the water. It's New York restorative in that sense, but it's very loud. So how do these things work together? Well, I'm going to give you an example in New York. It's called Pately Park, and it's just off a main roadway, probably four or five lanes of traffic. It's right in the heart of the city and it's flooded with water.|||通学更加适合步行且更加安全。在我看来，不同的城市可以在其不同的区域拥有这些元素。正如你所提到的，城市可以非常大。比如我在纽约市生活了很多年。那里有中央公园，但布鲁克林也有公园，布朗克斯也有公园，还有其他地方。当然，你身处一个岛上，所以你靠近水域，你能看到水。从这个意义上说，纽约具有恢复性，但它非常吵闹。那么这些东西是如何协同作用的呢？嗯，我要给你举一个纽约的例子。它叫佩特利公园（Pately Park），位于一条主干道旁，大概有四五车道宽。它位于市中心，到处都是水景。
So they have a screen of water rushing down one of the facades in this pocket pocket park. You must go there next time you're in New York. And you set off and you sit there and you hear this extraordinary sound of water tumbling down the surface of the facade and it just reduces all the noise that you might hear from the street. So it's an example of a micro-restroative space off a busy roadway that can just help restore your mental health whilst you want to break from work, whatever you're doing in the city. So New York, I think, has fantastic examples of restorative spaces. What I'd love to do with New York, though, and this is controversial possibly, that Central Park is one big, gigantic space. And I would love to see New York and Manhattan have an more equal distribution of greensprays across its area.
So they have a screen of water rushing down one of the facades in this pocket pocket park. You must go there next time you're in New York. And you set off and you sit there and you hear this extraordinary sound of water tumbling down the surface of the facade and it just reduces all the noise that you might hear from the street. So it's an example of a micro-restroative space off a busy roadway that can just help restore your mental health whilst you want to break from work, whatever you're doing in the city. So New York, I think, has fantastic examples of restorative spaces. What I'd love to do with New York, though, and this is controversial possibly, that Central Park is one big, gigantic space. And I would love to see New York and Manhattan have an more equal distribution of greensprays across its area.|||所以在这个袖珍公园里，水幕沿着其中一个建筑立面倾泻而下。下次你去纽约时一定要去那里看看。当你出发并在那里坐下时，你会听到水流从立面表面倾泻而下的美妙声音，它能消减你可能从街上听到的所有噪音。因此，这是一个位于繁忙道路旁的微型恢复性空间的例子，当你想要从工作中抽身出来，无论你在城市里做什么，它都能帮助恢复你的心理健康。所以我觉得纽约拥有极佳的恢复性空间范例。不过，我对纽约最想做的事情是——这可能具有争议——中央公园是一个巨大的空间。我希望看到纽约和曼哈顿在其整个区域内更均衡地分布绿地。
Well, it's so built up. It's a little hard, I mean, short of knocking down buildings. I mean, they did do the High Line, though, a number of years ago, right, which is a beautiful park that I think is very restorative in the sense that you can enjoy it. You can see nature and you can see the buildings. You can, you know, look beyond to the water. Absolutely. The Highlands are a perfect example of connecting the tissue of a city. together through the use of a linear park. It's a perfect example. So you're in Charlottesville. Is that a restorative city? It's a good question. There are many times when I walk around and drive around Charlestville and think it's very, very restorative. There are other times I think I'm in a hellscape of
Well, it's so built up. It's a little hard, I mean, short of knocking down buildings. I mean, they did do the High Line, though, a number of years ago, right, which is a beautiful park that I think is very restorative in the sense that you can enjoy it. You can see nature and you can see the buildings. You can, you know, look beyond to the water. Absolutely. The Highlands are a perfect example of connecting the tissue of a city. together through the use of a linear park. It's a perfect example. So you're in Charlottesville. Is that a restorative city? It's a good question. There are many times when I walk around and drive around Charlestville and think it's very, very restorative. There are other times I think I'm in a hellscape of|||嗯，这里开发得太满了。我的意思是，这有点难，除非把建筑拆了。不过，他们几年前确实修建了高线公园（High Line），对吧？那是一个美丽的公园，我认为它非常有恢复性，因为你可以在那里享受乐趣。你可以看到自然，也可以看到建筑。你知道，还可以眺望远处的河水。完全正确。高线公园（High Line）是通过使用线性公园将城市的文脉连接在一起的完美范例。这是一个完美的例子。那么你在夏洛茨维尔（Charlottesville）。那是一座具有恢复性的城市吗？这是个好问题。有很多次，当我步行或开车穿过夏洛茨维尔时，我觉得它非常非常有恢复性。但也有其他时候，我觉得自己身处一个宛如地狱般的
noise and strip moles. So I think Charlottesville has beautiful views out to the mountains, the idea of extent that I was talking about earlier. It has a lot of murals that contributes to the sense of fascination I talked about. But Charlottesville is not a walkable city. And it could be. It could so easily be a walkable city. We have a downtown mall that's pedestrianized, a wonderful example of walkability, but it's only probably less than a mile long. So I come from the UK. I came here 2015 from a very walkable and cyclable city, which is Edinburgh in Scotland. And I thought about getting a bike in Charlottesville and I did not. I was advised not to.
noise and strip moles. So I think Charlottesville has beautiful views out to the mountains, the idea of extent that I was talking about earlier. It has a lot of murals that contributes to the sense of fascination I talked about. But Charlottesville is not a walkable city. And it could be. It could so easily be a walkable city. We have a downtown mall that's pedestrianized, a wonderful example of walkability, but it's only probably less than a mile long. So I come from the UK. I came here 2015 from a very walkable and cyclable city, which is Edinburgh in Scotland. And I thought about getting a bike in Charlottesville and I did not. I was advised not to.|||噪声和条状购物中心的景象中。所以我觉得夏洛茨维尔能看到美丽的山景，这契合了我之前谈到的延展感的概念。它有很多壁画，这有助于营造我所谈到的着迷感。但夏洛茨维尔不是一座适合步行的城市。其实它本可以是的。它完全可以轻而易举地成为一座适合步行的城市。我们有一个实行步行街改造的市中心购物中心，这是步行便利性的绝佳范例，但它可能还不到一英里长。我来自英国。我2015年从一个非常适合步行和骑行的城市——苏格兰的爱丁堡来到这里。我曾考虑在夏洛茨维尔买辆自行车，但我没有买。有人劝我不要买。
But that was my mode of transport in the UK. So I think we could be doing better. And my students, I teach healthy cities to graduate students here at UVA. And they're often saying to me, Jenny, you think of the examples you're giving us are from Europe. I've just talked about Paris. I've talked about Edinburgh. They say it's not possible here in the US.
But that was my mode of transport in the UK. So I think we could be doing better. And my students, I teach healthy cities to graduate students here at UVA. And they're often saying to me, Jenny, you think of the examples you're giving us are from Europe. I've just talked about Paris. I've talked about Edinburgh. They say it's not possible here in the US.|||但那是我在英国的交通方式。所以我认为我们本可以做得更好。我的学生们——我在弗吉尼亚大学（UVA）教研究生健康城市课程。他们经常对我说：“珍妮，你举的例子都是来自欧洲的。”我刚刚谈到了巴黎，谈到了爱丁堡。他们说这在美国是不可能的。
And I dispute that. I think that cities like New York, Boston, Chicago are leading away in terms of certainly creating space for walking and cycling. And if you look at Amsterdam in the 1970s and 1960s, it was flooded with transport. They made an active decision to do something about it, just as Paris is doing right now. Now, you also write in your book about the neighborly city. How does city design influence the way that we interact with other people? How do you design places that will encourage people to be more neighborly?
And I dispute that. I think that cities like New York, Boston, Chicago are leading away in terms of certainly creating space for walking and cycling. And if you look at Amsterdam in the 1970s and 1960s, it was flooded with transport. They made an active decision to do something about it, just as Paris is doing right now. Now, you also write in your book about the neighborly city. How does city design influence the way that we interact with other people? How do you design places that will encourage people to be more neighborly?|||对此我持不同看法。我认为像纽约、波士顿、芝加哥这样的城市在为步行和骑行创造空间方面确实走在前列。如果你看看20世纪70年代和60年代的阿姆斯特丹，那里曾充斥着交通工具。他们做出积极的决定来改变现状，正如巴黎现在所做的那样。现在，你在书中还写到了邻里城市。城市设计是如何影响我们与他人互动的方式的？你如何设计能够鼓励人们更具邻里守望精神的场所？
I'm going to go back to nature as an example. It's just one example. But there's a lot of research emerging now to show that pocket parks allow people to sit and stop and intermingle with one another. there's evidence to show that we have a higher sense of trust of our neighbours if we have access to pocket parks and green space and street trees. There's a famous study that was done in a public park, in a city, which involved dropping a dollar on the pavement. And they did two scenarios, one in the park and one on a busy urban street with no green space. And people were much more likely to give the dollar back if they saw it being dropped. the park than they were on the street. So this is the kind of research that we do, you know,
I'm going to go back to nature as an example. It's just one example. But there's a lot of research emerging now to show that pocket parks allow people to sit and stop and intermingle with one another. there's evidence to show that we have a higher sense of trust of our neighbours if we have access to pocket parks and green space and street trees. There's a famous study that was done in a public park, in a city, which involved dropping a dollar on the pavement. And they did two scenarios, one in the park and one on a busy urban street with no green space. And people were much more likely to give the dollar back if they saw it being dropped. the park than they were on the street. So this is the kind of research that we do, you know,|||我还是以自然为例。这只是一个例子。但现在有大量新兴研究表明，袖珍公园可以让人们坐下来、停下脚步并相互交融。有证据表明，如果我们能够接触到袖珍公园、绿地和行道树，我们对邻居的信任感就会更高。曾经有一项在城市的公共公园里进行的著名研究，内容是在人行道上扔下一美元。他们设置了两种场景，一个在公园里，另一个在没有绿地、交通繁忙的城市街道上。如果人们看到美元是在公园里掉落的，他们比在街上更有可能把美元归还。所以这就是我们所做的研究，你知道的，
to show that these values of altruism, trust, place belonging are really helps and supported by having access to green space. So nature is just one example. So how do you do more research into the mental health impacts of cities on people? Do you look at people in cities that say aren't green or blue or neighborly and compare them with people in cities that have? And those attributes and is the research based on self-reports or do you use other measurement methods? So two good questions. Firstly, I'll take the measures. We do both. We ask people how they feel using self-report, validated scales from psychology. Really important to ask people how they feel, but we also try and capture their physiology as they're moving about through space. So we have
to show that these values of altruism, trust, place belonging are really helps and supported by having access to green space. So nature is just one example. So how do you do more research into the mental health impacts of cities on people? Do you look at people in cities that say aren't green or blue or neighborly and compare them with people in cities that have? And those attributes and is the research based on self-reports or do you use other measurement methods? So two good questions. Firstly, I'll take the measures. We do both. We ask people how they feel using self-report, validated scales from psychology. Really important to ask people how they feel, but we also try and capture their physiology as they're moving about through space. So we have|||旨在表明，利他主义、信任、地方归属感等价值观确实可以通过接触绿地得到帮助和支持。所以自然只是一个例子。那么，你如何对城市对人们心理健康的影响进行更多的研究呢？你们是否会观察那些处于缺乏绿色、蓝色或邻里氛围等城市的居民，并将他们与拥有这些属性的城市的居民进行比较？这种研究是基于自我报告，还是你们使用其他测量方法？这是两个很好的问题。首先，我来回答测量方法。我们两者都采用。我们使用心理学中经过验证的自我报告量表来询问人们的感受。询问人们的感受非常重要，但我们也试图捕捉他们在空间中移动时的生理反应。所以我们有
smart watches that will capture their heart rate. We have neural headsets that will capture to what's going on in people's brains as they're moving through space. We can take those kind of biometrics data and correlate it with the self-report data. And usually the two tally, not always, but really important to ask people how they feel. And then what was the first question? Do you look at people who are in, say, green or blue or neighborly cities and compare them to people who are in other non-restorative places? We do exactly that.
smart watches that will capture their heart rate. We have neural headsets that will capture to what's going on in people's brains as they're moving through space. We can take those kind of biometrics data and correlate it with the self-report data. And usually the two tally, not always, but really important to ask people how they feel. And then what was the first question? Do you look at people who are in, say, green or blue or neighborly cities and compare them to people who are in other non-restorative places? We do exactly that.|||可以捕捉他们心率的智能手表。我们有神经头戴设备，可以捕捉人们在空间中移动时大脑中发生的情况。我们可以将这类生物识别数据与自我报告数据进行关联。通常这两者是吻合的，虽然并非总是如此，但询问人们的感受真的很重要。那么第一个问题是什么来着？你们是否会观察身处绿色、蓝色或邻里城市的人，并将他们与身处其他缺乏恢复性场所的人进行比较？我们正是这样做的。
So epimetologists would certainly do that in public health. They would crunch public health data from neighborhoods with access to space to green space, for instance, in parks, and those that don't. In my field, we always have this kind of oppositional environment, one that's very green and one that's completely gray. So, you know, we know that extremes of environment have a very strong difference on mental health outcomes. I think you've found that certain types of city environments foster pro-social behavior and altruism, but I'm wondering, isn't it possible that people who are already altruistic and pro-social would go to live in these places? Well, that's an interesting question.
So epimetologists would certainly do that in public health. They would crunch public health data from neighborhoods with access to space to green space, for instance, in parks, and those that don't. In my field, we always have this kind of oppositional environment, one that's very green and one that's completely gray. So, you know, we know that extremes of environment have a very strong difference on mental health outcomes. I think you've found that certain types of city environments foster pro-social behavior and altruism, but I'm wondering, isn't it possible that people who are already altruistic and pro-social would go to live in these places? Well, that's an interesting question.|||流行病学家在公共卫生领域肯定会这样做。他们会分析来自拥有空间（例如公园等绿地）的社区与没有这些空间的社区的公共卫生数据。在我的领域，我们总是存在这种相对立的环境，一种是非常绿色的，另一种是完全灰色的。所以，你知道的，我们知道极端环境对心理健康结果有着非常强烈的影响。我想你已经发现某些类型的城市环境会促进亲社会行为和利他主义，但我在想，有没有可能原本就很利他、具有亲社会性的人才会选择去这些地方生活呢？嗯，这是一个有趣的问题。
And a lot of the research I've just referred to, particularly the large population health data, the scientists control very carefully for demographics, so they will only match alike with like. So a lot of the work I did in Scotland, for instance, matched neighborhoods on very carefully controlled demographic variables. So people who had similar levels, who lived in similar types of housing. And you have to really control for that because, of course, richer areas have better access to higher quality green space. So most of my work doesn't look at that population. It looks at people who are poor, who are living in some of the worst environments in our cities. You just talked about money. There is a cost involved in making a city
And a lot of the research I've just referred to, particularly the large population health data, the scientists control very carefully for demographics, so they will only match alike with like. So a lot of the work I did in Scotland, for instance, matched neighborhoods on very carefully controlled demographic variables. So people who had similar levels, who lived in similar types of housing. And you have to really control for that because, of course, richer areas have better access to higher quality green space. So most of my work doesn't look at that population. It looks at people who are poor, who are living in some of the worst environments in our cities. You just talked about money. There is a cost involved in making a city|||我刚才提到的许多研究，特别是大型人口健康数据，科学家们对人口统计学变量进行了非常仔细的控制，因此他们只会进行同类匹配。例如，我在苏格兰做的许多工作都是在经过精心控制的人口统计学变量基础上来匹配社区的。也就是拥有相似水平、住在相似类型住房里的人。你必须对这些因素进行真正的控制，因为当然了，富裕地区能更好地获得更高质量的绿地。所以我大部分的工作并没有关注这一人群。它关注的是那些生活在我们的城市中一些最糟糕环境中的穷人。你刚才谈到了金钱。打造一座城市需要付出成本
restorative. And I'm wondering what happens in some countries where they don't have the resources. Is it possible in some of the lower socioeconomic countries in the world for them to still have restorative cities? I really believe so. I've not been to South America, but I'm going shortly to Mexico. Go City. But I have talked to colleagues in Colombia, and they have made remarkable progress with the idea of Siclovia, closing a public street on a Sunday, allowing people to walk, run, play, cycle without access to cars. They also have some really good examples of this idea of play streets, closing a street, allowing children to play on the street at the weekend or closing a street nearby a school.
restorative. And I'm wondering what happens in some countries where they don't have the resources. Is it possible in some of the lower socioeconomic countries in the world for them to still have restorative cities? I really believe so. I've not been to South America, but I'm going shortly to Mexico. Go City. But I have talked to colleagues in Colombia, and they have made remarkable progress with the idea of Siclovia, closing a public street on a Sunday, allowing people to walk, run, play, cycle without access to cars. They also have some really good examples of this idea of play streets, closing a street, allowing children to play on the street at the weekend or closing a street nearby a school.|||具备恢复性，我想知道在那些缺乏资源的国家会发生什么。世界上一些社会经济地位较低的国家是否也有可能拥有恢复性城市？我坚信会的。我没去过南美洲，但我很快要去墨西哥城。不过我和哥伦比亚的同行交流过，他们在“西克洛维亚”（Siclovia，意为自行车道）这一理念上取得了显著进展——即在周日关闭公共街道，让人们在没有汽车的情况下散步、跑步、玩耍、骑自行车。他们还有一些关于“游戏街道”理念的极好例子，比如关闭一条街道，让孩子们在周末在街上玩耍，或者关闭学校附近的街道。
So I do believe there are some really good case studies in South America, but I think you raise a really good question because a lot of the research has done in why I would call the developed world, the Western industrialized nations with money, and we really have very little evidence of the value of restorative city attributes like nature in, let's say, low to middle income countries. It's changing, but it's changing very slowly. A lot of the ideas that you are suggesting need to be addressed on a large scale by governments and city planners. But what if people want to make some changes in their own communities?
So I do believe there are some really good case studies in South America, but I think you raise a really good question because a lot of the research has done in why I would call the developed world, the Western industrialized nations with money, and we really have very little evidence of the value of restorative city attributes like nature in, let's say, low to middle income countries. It's changing, but it's changing very slowly. A lot of the ideas that you are suggesting need to be addressed on a large scale by governments and city planners. But what if people want to make some changes in their own communities?|||所以我确实相信南美洲有一些非常好的案例研究，但我认为你提出了一个非常好的问题，因为许多研究都是在我所说的发达世界、即有钱的西方工业化国家中进行的，而在中低收入国家中，我们确实很少有关于诸如自然等恢复性城市属性价值的证据。这种情况正在改变，但速度非常慢。你所提出的许多想法需要由政府和城市规划者进行大规模地解决。但是，如果人们想在自己的社区做出一些改变呢？
Are there things that we can do as individuals in our own neighborhood to make it more restorative? Indeed, there are, and I do work with community groups on some very small scale insertions, microinsurgens. and we've demonstrated that these can improve mental health or well-being. So, for instance, in West Palm Beach, we did a temporary microinsurgeon. You can call it all sorts of things, acupuncture for cities or just a pop-up for a city. We screened the noise. It was a pocket space. It was next to a busy road.
Are there things that we can do as individuals in our own neighborhood to make it more restorative? Indeed, there are, and I do work with community groups on some very small scale insertions, microinsurgens. and we've demonstrated that these can improve mental health or well-being. So, for instance, in West Palm Beach, we did a temporary microinsurgeon. You can call it all sorts of things, acupuncture for cities or just a pop-up for a city. We screened the noise. It was a pocket space. It was next to a busy road.|||作为个人，我们能在自己的社区做些什么来让它更具恢复性？确实有，我确实与社区团体合作开展一些非常小规模的嵌入改造，即微型干预。我们已经证明这些可以改善心理健康或福祉。例如，在西棕榈滩，我们做了一次临时的微型干预。你可以叫它各种名字，比如城市针灸，或者仅仅是城市的快闪项目。我们隔绝了噪音。那是一个袖珍空间，紧邻一条繁忙的道路。
We put up bamboos and big planters. We provided seating. You don't have to provide very much to increase people's sense of subjective mental well-being and indeed their physiological well-being. And the results of that study are published. So I would say to people, if there's a vacant piece of land in your neighbourhood, try and come together, even if you can't change that piece of land permanently, do some kind of temporary pop-up and show how it could be used differently.
We put up bamboos and big planters. We provided seating. You don't have to provide very much to increase people's sense of subjective mental well-being and indeed their physiological well-being. And the results of that study are published. So I would say to people, if there's a vacant piece of land in your neighbourhood, try and come together, even if you can't change that piece of land permanently, do some kind of temporary pop-up and show how it could be used differently.|||我们竖起了竹子和大型花盆。我们提供了座椅。你不需要提供太多东西就能提高人们的主观心理福祉，甚至是生理福祉。该研究的结果已经发表。所以我对人们说，如果你的社区里有一块空地，试着聚集起来，即使你无法永久改变那块空地，也做一些临时的快闪项目，展示它如何可以被不同地使用。
It doesn't have to be a big space. It could just be a vacant pot of land on a street corner. And there are, of course, restrictions on what you can do with space, and you have to identify who owns it and get their permission to do a pop-up. But there are some really successful examples in the US of those types of pop-ups. Now, you started writing your book before the pandemic hit. Did COVID change the way people were thinking about these issues, and how did you change the manuscript once the pandemic set in?
It doesn't have to be a big space. It could just be a vacant pot of land on a street corner. And there are, of course, restrictions on what you can do with space, and you have to identify who owns it and get their permission to do a pop-up. But there are some really successful examples in the US of those types of pop-ups. Now, you started writing your book before the pandemic hit. Did COVID change the way people were thinking about these issues, and how did you change the manuscript once the pandemic set in?|||它不需要是一个很大的空间。它可能只是街角的一小块空地。当然，对于如何利用空间是有限制的，你必须弄清楚是谁拥有它，并获得他们的允许才能做一个快闪项目。但在美国，有一些这类快闪项目的非常成功的例子。现在，你在大流行爆发之前就开始写这本书了。新冠疫情改变了人们对这些问题的看法吗？一旦大流行开始，你是如何修改书稿的？
So the manuscript was almost completed March 2020, and it was due with the publisher, I think, by the end of May 2020. So we were just right at the beginning of the pandemic. And Leila and I wrote a preface to the book to adjust our thinking in light of COVID. But ultimately, what we were trying to do was really press the agenda on mental health. The book was really very timely from that perspective, because there have been really good and strong directives in cities to build for mobility in the US and in Europe. You know, comfortable streets, streets that foster walking and cycling. The chief surgeon of the US has spoken about this and advocated for it.
So the manuscript was almost completed March 2020, and it was due with the publisher, I think, by the end of May 2020. So we were just right at the beginning of the pandemic. And Leila and I wrote a preface to the book to adjust our thinking in light of COVID. But ultimately, what we were trying to do was really press the agenda on mental health. The book was really very timely from that perspective, because there have been really good and strong directives in cities to build for mobility in the US and in Europe. You know, comfortable streets, streets that foster walking and cycling. The chief surgeon of the US has spoken about this and advocated for it.|||所以书稿在2020年3月几乎已经完成，我想它应该在2020年5月底交给出版社。所以我们当时正处于大流行的初期。我和莱拉为这本书写了一篇序言，根据新冠疫情调整了我们的思路。但归根结底，我们试图做的是真正推进心理健康议程。从这个角度来看，这本书确实非常及时，因为在美国和欧洲，城市中一直有很好且强有力的指令来建设交通出行系统。你知道的，舒适的街道，促进步行和骑行的街道。美国外科医生总长曾谈到这一点并为此进行倡导。
But we really felt that mental health had been left out of that equation. And so the book was really an attempt to leverage a lot of scientific data to really put mental health. health higher up the agenda. COVID did that for us anyway. We all talk about mental health now. We have all experienced mental health issues because of COVID. And the stigma of mental health, I think, has declined since COVID because of the difficulties we've all experienced. In the 1960s and 70s, American urban planners started to create these planned cities. And there are a few near where I live, for example, there's Columbia, Maryland, Rest in Virginia. have you looked at these planned cities and were they successful?
But we really felt that mental health had been left out of that equation. And so the book was really an attempt to leverage a lot of scientific data to really put mental health. health higher up the agenda. COVID did that for us anyway. We all talk about mental health now. We have all experienced mental health issues because of COVID. And the stigma of mental health, I think, has declined since COVID because of the difficulties we've all experienced. In the 1960s and 70s, American urban planners started to create these planned cities. And there are a few near where I live, for example, there's Columbia, Maryland, Rest in Virginia. have you looked at these planned cities and were they successful?|||但我们确实觉得心理健康被遗漏在这个等式之外了。因此，这本书实际上是试图利用大量的科学数据，真正将心理健康放在议程的更高位置。无论如何，新冠疫情为我们做到了这一点。我们现在都在谈论心理健康。因为新冠疫情，我们都经历过心理健康问题。我认为，自从疫情爆发以来，由于我们都经历过困难，心理健康带来的污名化已经有所减弱。在20世纪60和70年代，美国城市规划者开始创建这些规划城市。在我住的地方附近就有几个，例如马里兰州的哥伦比亚市，弗吉尼亚州的雷斯顿。你研究过这些规划城市吗？它们成功吗？
I know a little bit about Reston. I've not been there, but I saw a film about it. And I think, I don't know. I'd have to go and ask the residents. I can't speak on their behalf, and I wouldn't want to. I think there are certain qualities about Reston that I think would be very appealing as a place to live. It has access to water. It has a lot of green space.
I know a little bit about Reston. I've not been there, but I saw a film about it. And I think, I don't know. I'd have to go and ask the residents. I can't speak on their behalf, and I wouldn't want to. I think there are certain qualities about Reston that I think would be very appealing as a place to live. It has access to water. It has a lot of green space.|||我对雷斯顿略知一二。我没去过那里，但我看过一部关于它的电影。我想，我不知道。我得去问问居民。我不能代表他们发言，也不想这么做。我认为雷斯顿具备某些特质，作为居住地会非常具有吸引力。它临近水域。它拥有大量的绿地。
It looks very walkable. They seems to have been a driver to make it very diverse and inclusive. I don't know if that's true or not. The film I saw was made several years ago. So without really seeing these neighborhoods, I'd be wary of giving my opinion. What about the kind of mixed-use development that seems to be popping up now so that people can live in a place that is sort of urban, but you've got stores and store fronts and places to sit and commune with people? Is that part of what you're advocating for?
It looks very walkable. They seems to have been a driver to make it very diverse and inclusive. I don't know if that's true or not. The film I saw was made several years ago. So without really seeing these neighborhoods, I'd be wary of giving my opinion. What about the kind of mixed-use development that seems to be popping up now so that people can live in a place that is sort of urban, but you've got stores and store fronts and places to sit and commune with people? Is that part of what you're advocating for?|||它看起来非常适合步行。那里似乎有一种推动力，使其变得非常多元化和包容。我不知道这是否属实。我看的电影是几年前拍的。因此，在没有真正亲眼看到这些社区之前，我在发表意见时会持谨慎态度。现在似乎正在涌现的那种混合用途开发项目怎么样？人们可以住在一种有点像城市的地方，但那里有商店、店面以及可以坐下来与人交流的地方。这属于你所倡导的一部分吗？
Absolutely. And we do address that in the book. And there's a ton of evidence, scientific evidence, to show that mixed use. And actually higher density urban living fosters all sorts of benefits for mental health, social health, physical health. So my neighborhood that I live when I'm not in Charlottesville is in Edinburgh. It's Southside Edinburgh. I have access to everything I need, really. within a 15, 20-minute walk.
Absolutely. And we do address that in the book. And there's a ton of evidence, scientific evidence, to show that mixed use. And actually higher density urban living fosters all sorts of benefits for mental health, social health, physical health. So my neighborhood that I live when I'm not in Charlottesville is in Edinburgh. It's Southside Edinburgh. I have access to everything I need, really. within a 15, 20-minute walk.|||绝对是的。我们在书中确实探讨了这一点。有大量的证据——科学证据表明，混合用途——实际上是更高密度的城市生活——对心理健康、社会健康、身体健康都有各种各样的好处。所以当我不在夏洛茨维尔时，我居住的社区在爱丁堡。那是爱丁堡南部。我步行15到20分钟，就能获得我真正需要的一切。
And Scotland is one of the first countries in the world to actually advocate for the 15-and-20-minute city. And it's doing five or six case studies of cities in Scotland and trying to implement that plan. I know it's become slightly controversial. I don't quite know why. I don't understand what the controversy is about. It seems to be very sensible.
And Scotland is one of the first countries in the world to actually advocate for the 15-and-20-minute city. And it's doing five or six case studies of cities in Scotland and trying to implement that plan. I know it's become slightly controversial. I don't quite know why. I don't understand what the controversy is about. It seems to be very sensible.|||苏格兰是世界上最早真正倡导“15分钟到20分钟城市”的国家之一。它正在苏格兰的城市中开展五到六个案例研究，并试图实施该计划。我知道这已经变得略具争议。我不太清楚为什么。我不明白争议在哪里。这看起来非常明智。
If you can drop your child off at a nursery or school within walking distance or a quick bus route from home and then go to your office within that neighbourhood, get your food, your provisions, your exercise within that neighbourhood. It makes a lot of sense to me. And the country are just site, or a city our site, sorry, that's doing this very well as Barcelona. And the example we use in the book as a super block. And that's an idea of a series of blocks in which traffic has been reduced. Everything that you need is available in that neighborhood. I grew up near the ocean and I lived for almost two decades on a lake that was actually less than 10 miles from downtown D.C. And I called Looking Out on the Water every
If you can drop your child off at a nursery or school within walking distance or a quick bus route from home and then go to your office within that neighbourhood, get your food, your provisions, your exercise within that neighbourhood. It makes a lot of sense to me. And the country are just site, or a city our site, sorry, that's doing this very well as Barcelona. And the example we use in the book as a super block. And that's an idea of a series of blocks in which traffic has been reduced. Everything that you need is available in that neighborhood. I grew up near the ocean and I lived for almost two decades on a lake that was actually less than 10 miles from downtown D.C. And I called Looking Out on the Water every|||如果你能在步行距离内或从家出发乘车不远的地方把孩子送到托儿所或学校，然后在这个社区内去办公室，在这个社区里买到食物、日用品，进行锻炼。这对我来说很有意义。做得很好的国家的一个地方，或者说城市的一个地方——抱歉，是巴塞罗那。我们在书中使用的例子是超级街区（super block）。这是一个关于减少交通流量的一系列街区的理念。你所需要的一切都可以在那个社区里找到。我在海边长大，在距离华盛顿特区市中心不到10英里的一个湖边生活了近二十年。我把每天眺望水面称为
day, my lake therapy. In the book, you talk about the importance of blue spaces. What is it? What is going on in our brains when we're near water that is so good for our mental health and well-being. Those four attributes I mentioned earlier, fascination, extent, compatibility and being away, water provides that in abundance. I think the other thing that makes water so restorative is it's a dynamic quality. It moves and it changes its patterns. It changes its sound as it flows over different kinds of surfaces. It changes in response to light falling on it and over it. So it changes in response to daylight and season. So it's much more dynamic.
day, my lake therapy. In the book, you talk about the importance of blue spaces. What is it? What is going on in our brains when we're near water that is so good for our mental health and well-being. Those four attributes I mentioned earlier, fascination, extent, compatibility and being away, water provides that in abundance. I think the other thing that makes water so restorative is it's a dynamic quality. It moves and it changes its patterns. It changes its sound as it flows over different kinds of surfaces. It changes in response to light falling on it and over it. So it changes in response to daylight and season. So it's much more dynamic.|||我的湖泊疗法。你在书中谈到了蓝色空间的重要性。究竟是什么？当我们在水边时，我们的大脑中发生了什么，这对我们的心理健康和福祉如此有益。我前面提到的那四个属性——着迷感、延展感、契合感和抽离感，水都极为丰富地提供了。我认为让水如此具有恢复性的另一个原因是它具有动态属性。它会流动并改变其模式。当它流过不同种类的表面时，它的声音会发生变化。它随着落在其上和上方的光线而变化。因此它随日光和季节而变化。所以它更具动态性。
I mean, yes, vegetation and trees are dynamic in that they are changing seasonally too. But water is super dynamic and it's one of the most restorative attributes. But access has become limited. A lot of cities have turned their back on the river. You see New York now. It's facing the river. It's got parks and access, both in Brooklyn and Manhattan. and it's engaging with the water in a way that perhaps it didn't in the past.
I mean, yes, vegetation and trees are dynamic in that they are changing seasonally too. But water is super dynamic and it's one of the most restorative attributes. But access has become limited. A lot of cities have turned their back on the river. You see New York now. It's facing the river. It's got parks and access, both in Brooklyn and Manhattan. and it's engaging with the water in a way that perhaps it didn't in the past.|||我的意思是，是的，植被和树木也是动态的，因为它们也在随季节变化。但水是超级动态的，它是最具恢复性的属性之一。然而获取的途径变得有限了。许多城市都背对河流。你看现在的纽约。它正对着河流。它拥有公园和通道，无论在布鲁克林还是曼哈顿，它都在以一种过去可能没有的方式与水亲近。
I've seen other cities now turning to their waterfronts to increase access. It's super important. I think one of the issues with water also, though, has become safety. A lot of parents have a lot of concerns about access to water for children, but it can be designed sustainably and safely. There are techniques. What are you working on now? What are the questions that you're trying to answer that you haven't dealt with up until this point in your research?
I've seen other cities now turning to their waterfronts to increase access. It's super important. I think one of the issues with water also, though, has become safety. A lot of parents have a lot of concerns about access to water for children, but it can be designed sustainably and safely. There are techniques. What are you working on now? What are the questions that you're trying to answer that you haven't dealt with up until this point in your research?|||我看到其他城市现在也转向它们的滨水区以增加通道。这超级重要。不过我认为水资源带来的问题之一也成了安全问题。很多父母对儿童接触水有很多担忧，但它可以被设计得既可持续又安全。有相关的技术。你现在在做什么研究？在你目前的研究中，有哪些问题是你试图回答但尚未解决的？
So I'm working on a C-quarter restorative cities, and it's called restorative architecture, and it's the exact same hypothesis that how we design our interiors and our architecture can really support mental health and urban design. And I'm working in the same way. The way that I work is I look at all the scientific evidence. It takes a very, very long time to synthesize it. It's thousands of studies. And I translate that evidence into very simple principles, both for designers, but also for communities and lay people to use, for people in policy.
So I'm working on a C-quarter restorative cities, and it's called restorative architecture, and it's the exact same hypothesis that how we design our interiors and our architecture can really support mental health and urban design. And I'm working in the same way. The way that I work is I look at all the scientific evidence. It takes a very, very long time to synthesize it. It's thousands of studies. And I translate that evidence into very simple principles, both for designers, but also for communities and lay people to use, for people in policy.|||因此，我正在致力于“恢复性城市”的续篇（译者注：原文C-quarter应为sequel之误），它被称为“恢复性建筑”，其假设完全相同，即我们如何设计室内和建筑才能真正支持心理健康和城市设计。我的工作方式也一样。我的工作方式是查看所有的科学证据。综合这些证据需要非常非常长的时间，这是数千项研究。我将这些证据转化为非常简单的原则，既适合设计师使用，也适合社区和普通人使用，以及政策制定者使用。
And I work with an illustrator to make that scientific data very graphic and easily understandable. And it's a big project. it's going to be a very similar style of book, but focusing on interiors rather than urban design. Can you give us any clues as to what you're learning now? And it's only interiors, not the exterior buildings, but interiors or both? It's both. I would say it's the space between buildings and the buildings themselves. And it's dealing with a whole host of design attributes that we touched upon in restorative cities, but it's going into a lot more detail. So things like color,
And I work with an illustrator to make that scientific data very graphic and easily understandable. And it's a big project. it's going to be a very similar style of book, but focusing on interiors rather than urban design. Can you give us any clues as to what you're learning now? And it's only interiors, not the exterior buildings, but interiors or both? It's both. I would say it's the space between buildings and the buildings themselves. And it's dealing with a whole host of design attributes that we touched upon in restorative cities, but it's going into a lot more detail. So things like color,|||我与一位插画家合作，使这些科学数据非常形象且易于理解。这是一个大项目。它将是一本风格非常相似的书，但重点是室内而不是城市设计。你能给我们提供一些线索，让我们知道你现在学到了什么吗？这仅仅是室内，还是不包括外部建筑，仅仅是室内还是两者兼有？两者兼有。我想说是建筑之间的空间以及建筑本身。它涉及我们在《恢复性城市》中触及的一大堆设计属性，但会进行更深入的细节探讨。比如颜色、
pattern, fractals, textiles, light, sound, the form of space. So a lot more in terms of architectural design attributes. And not to blow your whole story, but are there cities that you're seeing now that have some of these attributes? I mean, where are you focusing on your research right now? So that's a good question because I just actually spent Friday of last week really doing some deep research into case studies. And I've got to say, some of them are coming from Europe.
pattern, fractals, textiles, light, sound, the form of space. So a lot more in terms of architectural design attributes. And not to blow your whole story, but are there cities that you're seeing now that have some of these attributes? I mean, where are you focusing on your research right now? So that's a good question because I just actually spent Friday of last week really doing some deep research into case studies. And I've got to say, some of them are coming from Europe.|||图案、分形、纺织品、光线、声音、空间的形状。所以在建筑设计属性方面有更多内容。为了不剧透你的整本书，你现在有没有看到哪些城市具备其中一些属性？我的意思是，你目前的研究重点在哪里？这是一个好问题，因为上周五我刚刚花时间对案例研究进行了深入研究。我必须说，其中一些案例来自欧洲。
I'm going to Helsinki and Stockholm in August to do some research. And there are some wonderful examples there are libraries and public buildings that have extraordinary commitment to quality design. And I know that there exists here in the US, but I do find Europe is my kind of bed of exemplars just because I know it much better. But I'd welcome examples from your listeners. All right. Well, this is very interesting.
I'm going to Helsinki and Stockholm in August to do some research. And there are some wonderful examples there are libraries and public buildings that have extraordinary commitment to quality design. And I know that there exists here in the US, but I do find Europe is my kind of bed of exemplars just because I know it much better. But I'd welcome examples from your listeners. All right. Well, this is very interesting.|||我将于8月前往赫尔辛基和斯德哥尔摩进行一些研究。那里有一些极佳的例子，有对高质量设计有着非凡承诺的图书馆和公共建筑。我知道美国也存在这种情况，但我确实发现欧洲是我的模范城市之源，仅仅因为我对它更熟悉。不过我也欢迎听众们提供例子。好的。嗯，这非常有趣。
I want to thank you so much for spending time talking to me today. Well, thank you for your interest, and I really hope it's engaging your audience. I think it will. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe. and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound
I want to thank you so much for spending time talking to me today. Well, thank you for your interest, and I really hope it's engaging your audience. I think it will. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe. and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound|||非常感谢你今天花时间与我交谈。谢谢你对这方面的兴趣，我真心希望它能吸引你的听众。我想会的。您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在苹果、声田、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）以前的节目。如果您喜欢您所听到的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org 与我们联系。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。我们的音频
editor is Chris Kondyian. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
editor is Chris Kondyian. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.|||剪辑师是克里斯·孔迪扬（Chris Kondyian）。感谢您的收听。我是代表美国心理学会的吉姆·米尔斯。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。